okay so hi everyone so huge thanks to
Alexander hyung you and Sammy for
organizing this incredible workshop and
excited to be here and thanks everyone
for coming I know I'm between you and
lunch so I'll try and keep things on
time so today I'm really excited to talk
a bit about transfer learning in the
context of deep learning so transfer
learning is this incredibly popular
technique it's used almost everywhere
that we apply deep neural networks but
there's also this challenge that we
really don't understand many aspects of
it all that all that well and so by the
end of this talk I hope that you know
you have some sense of all the many
different ways it comes up and also some
of the interesting open questions there
are in the field so a lot of this talk
is going to be based off of a paper
understanding transfer learning for
medical imaging
that's joint work with my collaborators
chauhan jeong john Kleinberg and sami
Benjo okay so let's dive right in what
is transfer learning very basic so in
the settings that we're gonna really be
studying what you do is you first you
learn classifier on some tasks let's
call it Tosca and sometimes we call this
pre-training then having learned Koski
you continue training this classifier on
a new task task B and the goal is really
to get good performance on task B so the
goal is to get good performance on toss
B you might ask why train on task a at
all and the general belief in the
community is that if you know task a is
sort of complex and diverse and very
general then by going through this
process of training on task a hopefully
you've learned useful things that you
can sort of transfer over when you start
retraining on on task B so this
high-level framework actually has
connections to a lot of interesting work
that's come out from the the theoretical
perspective I think Zac mentioned some
in his talk earlier today and I wanted
to kind of give a quick point out to shy
and Devine who is maybe here no I don't
see him oh you're here you're here okay
in the front where
there's been a lot of interesting work
done in in this very related field of
domain adaptation to try and understand
this from a more formal framework and I
think the times really come to revisit
some of these ideas and see how we can
use them to give us better insights for
transfer learning in in the deep
learning context so speaking of transfer
learning and deep learning what does
that look like well it's very similar of
sorry very simple you sort of just
replace classifier with deep network so
you have this deep network it's gonna be
your classifier you randomly initialize
it and you train on toski and this will
be known as pre training then you take
this network and and it's sort of
converged to some set of parameters on
taos k and then you train it again this
time on task B and then voila you have
your final model that you're going to
deploy and it's it's hopefully going to
do great on on task B so this paradigm
is pretty simple but it's been extremely
successful and it's probably the
computer vision community that sort of
really showed us how successful this
could be in various applications so in
sort of specifically the current setting
what people do is pre train a large
convolutional neural network on some
data set of large images and you know
image net gets a special shout-out here
it's extremely popular for for pre
training so much so that there are sort
of entire papers saying why image net is
good for transfer learning but besides
that there are a couple of other data
sets so ms cocoa is a very popular big
computer vision benchmark for object
detection that sometimes used for pre
training and companies also tend to have
their own internal data sets which they
like using for pre training so a really
big one that Google likes using is jf th
has sort of three hundred million images
so absolutely enormous what's been
really interesting to see in the past
couple of years though is that transfer
learning has also become very popular in
applications in natural language
processing so in the past people were
able to transfer word embeddings so
you've probably seen these diagrams of
taking a word in your vocabulary getting
a vector representation and then these
vector representations of all of these
nice properties we could do that for a
while but it's only more recently that
sort of all of these a neural networks
that are named after Muppets for some
reason have have
have been developed and that lets us
transfer much more complex
representations of language and that's
shown to be very very successful in a
lot of standard natural language tasks
and now I have to mention the most
important part of transfer learning
which is github for transfer learning so
been mentioned in a talk in his talk
earlier that you know github can be this
very useful research resource and that's
definitely very true in transfer
learning so in transfer learning kind of
applications nobody actually bothers
with the pre-training stuff instead you
go to github and you sort of find the
model you're interested in and find all
of its pre trained weights and then you
just download it and then after you
download it you just perform the
fine-tuning for whatever tells you're
interested in and this is really
important because what this is enabled
is it's enabled people who totally
aren't working on sort of core machine
learning to apply transfer learning to
all of their problems and nowhere is
this more true than in medical imaging
where where it's sort of the entire
community has almost universally adopted
transfer learning as this paradigm and
what's the setup here
well the setup here is that you take
this sort of standard pre-trained
imagenet model something large and
complex like Inception v3 and then you
and then you have sort of these pre
trained weights on imagenet that you
sort of downloaded from somewhere so
imagenet has you know amongst other
things a whole bunch of different dog
breeds and then bizarrely you sort of
find two in this model to do all kinds
of medical predictions
so you find unit to predict and diseases
on chest x-rays diseases like retinal
diseases PET scans for early detection
of Alzheimer's and sort of the most
exotic application was even sort of
screening human embryos for IVF
treatments so people are just sort of
going out there and doing this and and
when you think about this this is kind
of bizarre because the reason the
community um you know wanted to do
transfer learning is this belief that
you sort of learned features on sort of
this this source dataset and then you
can kind of transfer all of this to to
your target tasks but of course medical
images and natural images are extremely
different to each other so it's kind of
interesting to understand what's what's
on here one final thing is these aren't
just sort of sort of turning into papers
where you see accuracies but they're
actually being deployed in clinic so
this is the example of one company
called idx which literally states that
it takes inception v3 pre turndown
imagenet and is using these to diagnose
retinal diseases and it's sort of out in
clinic right now so understanding their
examples the inception model mean for
this problem adversarial examples where
for medical images you mean I'm just
asking you're saying this is being
deployed and it's natural to think about
at the state examples for the infection
not that I mean so for example you know
I'm not talking about transferability I
mean that's that's an interesting
question sort of like how much can you
like kind of do like these are
completely different datasets so I think
that's also like a very interesting
thing to look at um but okay so while
we're kind of going ahead and sort of
deploying all of these there's kind of
this real challenge because even in the
natural image setting we actually don't
understand the effects of transfer
learning that well so I'm gonna review
some results which have just come out in
literally the last year that have really
challenged the common assumptions people
have on transfer learning so this is a
picture of Ms Coco and I mentioned it
earlier it's a very popular computer
vision benchmark for for doing object
detection so this is kind of what it
looks like you're trying to learn these
balance boxes and in almost all of the
competition entries the standard thing
to do is you pre train on imagenet and
then you sort of fine-tune your image
net a model on this this ms koko tusk
but then last year we got this paper
rethinking image Annette pre training
which basically showed just by kind of
being up maybe a little bit more careful
about how you pick your learning rate
you actually get exactly the same
results from random initialization as
you do with Swiss pre-training
now part of the reason people really
like pre-training on imagenet is again
this belief that it's kind of this big
diverse task and sort of if you train on
there you're gonna learn lots of
interesting features that you can kind
of reuse in lots of places so sort of
this underlying assumption is more data
is is great but then there was there's
another paper also just last year which
looked at pre training on jft which is
sort of this even bigger data set sort
of 300 million images and what they find
is that more true more pre training data
is not always better which is this sort
of very closely held assumption in the
community so in particular like they
sort of try training from random
initialization versus the entire data
set and in a bunch of places the
performances are actually really pretty
comparable other criterion if you fix
the number of iteration or training data
more source domain data is not better I
suspect that that won't be true right
it's like fitting more to the training
distribution it's not necessarily better
to the story features not necessarily
better so they're they're not fixing the
number of training iterations I think I
think they're literally just training to
convergence and see what
it's late right yeah right like you're
saying maybe you just sort of like dues
or barely stopping and then you just fix
it whatever the number is that you got
from the first amount of examples you do
the same number of updates for more data
or data points you know I'm not I'm not
sure it'll make a difference I see your
point and I'd have to check to see
exactly what they did but we can discuss
this offline yeah but yeah so so one
interesting point to kind of make here
and I think this is actually connected
to some of the theoretical work in this
that's that sort of come up in related
topics is if you do a better job of
actually picking the subsets of data
that you train on you actually do see
significant performance gains and I
think again this is a place where we can
kind of revisit some of the theoretical
ideas and see if we can do something
better this process is like relatively
ad-hoc and then finally one other paper
that came out just earlier this year do
better image net models transfer a
better has this kind of makes us
implicitly makes this very interesting
observation that when you decide to do
transfer learning you're not just taking
the the features but you're also
committing to an architecture it because
you download them both together and if
your task looks very different to
imagenet you know this is something you
should be be aware of and thinking about
and so do better image net models
transfer better well it's complicated
there's this nuance relationship that
depends on sort of how you regularize
during the training process the data set
the specifics of the data set and size
etc and so you sort of actually see a
lot of variability based off of all of
these conditions and sometimes you
actually get pretty similar performance
as usual
optimal weight optimal where um oh here
um yeah so this is optimal for transfer
so so this is sort of like standard ways
in which people can perform
regularization and this is how you tend
to download your pre trained models but
these are actually sort of not as good
for for doing transfer learning on
and.and here if you kind of train in a
slightly different way you actually end
up with better features for transfer
yeah really thorough so I highly
recommend reading it so they tried they
tried pretty much everything so they
tried this sort of like fixed feature
extractor setting where you sort of
freeze things and then just retrain some
of the top they also tried left
fine-tuning setting where you sort of
trained everything and they were also of
course comparing to training from from
scratch in these settings and so yeah
the kind of exact results vary a little
bit I think your fine-tuning maybe you
have like slightly less sensitivity to
some of these these settings
particularly for larger target datasets
but yeah they try everything so
definitely worth reading so this is all
in the natural image setting what about
in the medical image setting actually
hardly anything is explored in the
medical image setting which i think is
sort of something we should we could
really try and address from sort of two
angles firstly of course I think it's
important to study it because we're
actually deploying these in a lot of
places and it's important to understand
what's going on particularly is this is
sort of a very counterintuitive thing to
do
secondly I think this medical imaging
setting also captures a very interesting
part of captures an interesting sort of
regime in of performing transfer
learning so here your source and your
target tasks are extremely different to
each other like the data is different
the actual tasks you're going for is
different and as we'll see later there
are still some benefits that that come
up so sort of understanding why that
happens I think is sort of very
interesting to to explore from a purely
principled angle okay so in this talk so
first we'll do a quick sort of
performance evaluation of transfer just
to sort of set things up and then we're
going to go into a little bit more
detail and try
how is pre-training affecting the actual
features we're learning in our model and
for this I'll also touch on some work
we've been looking at on studying
representational similarity of networks
using canonical correlation analysis and
then finally and very interestingly and
also somewhat paradoxical we'll look at
some feature independent properties of
transfer that we see okay so the first
yeah so I'm fine um so I think the
question is sort of is there a precise
definition of what fine-tuning means in
this setting is there as in like you
sort of stop after some amount of time
or yeah is there something very
specified um the answer is like not
really you're really just sort of
training to convergence or pretty much
you're mostly stopping once you see that
like validation losses converged yeah
but okay so okay so so let's let's take
out let's breeze through the first part
um so first part we're gonna just try
and evaluate the actual performance
gains of transfer and to do this the way
people tend to evaluate transfer
learning because you're sort of
downloading these datasets from at least
sorry these models and these weights
from github is you just tend to evaluate
it on on standard imagenet architectures
so like some big complicated thing like
this but as I mentioned if your task
looks really different to imagenet its
kind of important to think about the
fact that you're making this implicit or
contextual choice and so in our
evaluation we also evaluated this much
smaller family of architectures that we
call CBR s they're really just vanilla
convolutional neural networks they're
called CBR s because the most sort of
popular and successful way of having a
vanilla Convenant these days is to have
a convolution followed by batch norm
followed by a rel u activation and these
things are really tiny there may be sort
of like one eighth to maybe one
twentieth the size of your full-fledged
two image net architecture
and then in terms of tasks we looked at
sort of two large-scale medical imaging
tasks one of them is diagnosing
different diseases from chest x-rays and
another one is diagnosing a certain kind
of retinal disease diabetic retinopathy
from scans of the the back of your eye
so we sort of run these experiments
across all these different architectures
random initialization and transfer
learning there was a lot of experiments
but we saw some clear takeaways so
firstly perhaps you know sort of falling
on from some of the results we've seen
in the natural image settings transfer
and random initialization actually
performed pretty comparably so here's a
sort of complicated results table we got
from our chest x-ray experiments and if
we look at where transfer and random
initialization perform comparably it's
actually for most of the table and in
some cases transfer even sorry random
initialization even outperforms transfer
secondly and and interestingly we
observed that these simple vanilla kind
of networks actually performed about as
well as these standard imagenet
architectures so we weren't really
trying to optimize for performance we
just wanted to try some simple things to
see what they look like compared to
image net like image net architecture is
because those architectures are really
pretty different to to what you might
want for the for the medical data that's
it
knows the simple architecture did you
also free trainer when this
yes yes so we pre trained them on
imagenet and then we and then fine-tuned
on the medical data sets yeah and then
sort of did those comparisons so the
data set sites so we actually buried
this so like kind of variations of this
or in the paper
um the full data set is around 200k
images I think which is kind of like
reasonable size but um sort of smallish
compared to image net which is like in
the millions so it's sort of interesting
to see that these sort of perform
comparably and then finally we also saw
that image net performance was not
actually indicative of how these
architectures would perform on a medical
task so what do I mean so let's look at
another results table so here's where I
at 50 and here are these two
architectures and here's what we saw
when we train them on image net these
architectures actually perform horribly
they're not designed for image net in a
way that I can sort of explain offline
but when we look at how they do on the
medical talk they're actually really
within sort of ballpark performance of
each other oh these architectures
they're just um they're just like a
family of simple vanilla convolutional
networks yeah we kind of just made them
up just because like we wanted something
extremely simple and I can explain why
sort of like you're sort of seeing this
difference I guess offline if you want
but there are kind of clear ways in
which image net is not the right way to
design your architecture for some of
these tasks and so we were able to take
advantage of that you mean the data set
size so yes it's something we've buried
but I'm full dataset sizes maybe two
hundred thousand images for both of them
yeah so I mean this last point is
interesting because other papers so this
paper undo better image net models
transfer better and even the papers that
been Rick's group has been working on on
this distribution shift and sort of
seeing if how performance car lights
across distribution shift does show that
there's this correlation but here here
we don't see this
okay so that was kind of a quick sort of
overview of what the the performance
evaluations look like but we like to go
beyond just the performance evaluation
we kind of really want to understand
what is transfer learning doing to our
architecture it's like what are we
gaining from from applying transfer
learning if anything at all and you know
I mean what we saw is like at a
performance level things are performing
about the same and so a really
fundamental question is well random
initialization and pre train weights
don't really look anything like each
other so we have one thing sitting in
one part of the space another set of
parameters sitting in another part of
the space what's happening during this
fine-tuning process is it just that it
doesn't really matter how you initialize
and then after you fine-tune you just
sort of change dramatically and
everything you initialize with is erased
so we could just kind of do whatever we
liked or is something else going on and
to alter that question what we really
want to do is we want to look at some of
the the latent representations of these
models and and take a measurement to see
how similar they are the problem with
trying to do this kind of an analysis is
that comparing representations from
different neural networks is is really
difficult there's this alignment problem
it's not like one neuron and a layer of
one network is going to correspond
nicely to to another neuron in the layer
of another network in fact there's no
reason that one neuron Maps so another
neuron at all it could be like a group
of neurons that are having the same
function as as a single neuron and
another network or one group mapping to
to another group so it's pretty
complicated but in another line of work
we've been looking at doing exactly
these kinds of comparisons using
canonical correlation analysis and the
basic framing is as follows we have some
data set of interest and we're going to
think of the neurons representation what
it's learned as what we call an
activation vector so we feed in this
kind of data set of interest and this
neuron is going to emit a scalar value
across all of these these input points
and we can literally just sort of stack
all of these and that'll form a vector
that we call the the activation vector
of this neuron
and so there's this sort of nice
framework where we kind of think of
these neurons as these activation
vectors and because layers are linearly
combining their neurons there are sort
of these subspaces that are sort of
spanned by their neurons so I'm so so
this is going to be at a very high level
the details of like all the the the
mathematical details of CCA are in their
relevant papers but so at a very high
level what we do is we take in two sets
of these neuron activity vectors and
they're typically going to be layers so
layer from one network a layer from
another network and then CCA will find
the linear combination of these neurons
that maximizes correlation and by
iteratively applying this process we can
basically get something like a
similarity score between these layers so
the score just tells us well you know
how how similar are the representations
learned by these layers sort of up to
sort of scaled linear transforms so
that's the way in which it addresses
this disalignment issue and so
previously we've kind of used this to
study various properties of
convolutional networks lately it's been
become quite popular in studying various
different kinds of language models in
NLP and more broadly this this kind of
entire area of studying similarity
between deep representations has quite a
lot of people who have been thinking
about it so we're I'm mostly gonna be
talking about using CCA but the first
paper here was probably this paper
called convergent learning by Lee
Osinski
Kuhn Lipson and Hopcroft in ic LR 2016
where instead of dealing with the
distributed problem they just tried to
find nice one-to-one mappings between
between neurons and different networks
then we kind of followed up with some of
the CCI work then there was a more
recent paper that's really pushing this
framework of having activation
vectors for neurons and and sort of
comparing similarities between subspaces
and then most recently there's been this
paper similarity of neural networks
representations revisited by Kornbluth
naruse Ely and Hinton that's broadly
proposing a kernel based similarity
measure and one one quick note about
sort of all of these is that I think
performing these sort of similarity
comparisons is a very
interesting way to try and get at what
your are neural networks are doing it's
kind of useful for interpretability and
it has interesting consequences for
things like compression and for model
Ensemble Inc and sort of all these
papers including our own are interesting
but I think there's a lot of scope for
doing things in a more formal and a more
principled way so although many of these
methods are built off of sort of
principle techniques a lot of the ways
in which we apply them are indeed
heuristic and we I don't think we can
claim we fully understand their
limitations or or where best to use them
so I think there are a whole bunch of
interesting questions in this space but
okay so going back to transfer learning
what are we going to do well we're gonna
do a very simple experiment we're gonna
train a bunch of networks from pre train
weights we're gonna train a bunch of
networks from random initialization then
we're going to apply CCA to just see how
similar they are to each other we want a
baseline so CCA is gonna give us these
similarity scores but we want some kind
of a baseline to compare these two and
so we're also going to look at the
similarity scores we get when we train a
population of networks from different
random initializations and apply CCA
there so here what the results look like
so along the x-axis are sort of
different architectures these blue
points are what you get from doing this
comparison from networks trained from
different random initializations and
these yellow points are what you get
when comparing pre train networks the
network's train from random
initialization yeah so so you do see
different architectures here but ah good
point no we didn't do that and that
would be kind of an interesting thing to
study definitely so-so but yeah so we
just kind of stayed within an
architecture but kind of the the
takeaway is that these blue points are
sort of higher up than these yellow
points what does that mean well it means
that models train from random
initializations seem to be more similar
to each other representational e than
then models trained from from pre
trained weights and transfer learning so
even though we're seeing the same
performance there is something different
happening at the the representational
level so yep
the different circles actually compare a
correspond to different networks so we
train multiple networks and then we just
sort of performed we put on these
comparisons yeah so it's it's it's
averaged over the layers um multiple I
mean I can tell you offline but sort of
slightly different layers for different
networks because their architectures are
a bit different but yeah taking a few
layers at different stages in the
network performing this comparison and
then averaging we have two distributions
and I get a bunch of samples Ramon
popular some examples of the other you
know like basically just be something
I'm wondering like any statistic is
going to be kind of you know but I think
this pertaining to a population but you
know this number of like thirty four and
a half
verse 36 is this enough to tell me
something about I think it is hard to
compare across architectures at least
the way we did this experiment just
because like we looked at different
layers and things and we'd have one
point see see a similarity actually
telling us a lot about of
transferability I think well not about
transferability but I think it is
actually telling us something about
what's similar versus what's not similar
like I think that was the whole point of
like kind of having this sort of
baseline comparison I guess in blue and
I think the fact that we see and nobody
tried like multiple networks for that so
I think the fact that we are seeing that
the blue things are higher like in most
cases is telling us that there is more
similarity there we train on the same
training data exactly yeah yeah because
we're interested in lots of questions
okay
we're interested we're interested in
yeah sort of seeing what this looks like
once we've trained on the medical data
yes oh yeah so like we're not done
making the conclusion yet but sort of
the first thing we saw was that like
performance is similar and so like
hypothesis one is like it kind of
doesn't matter how you initialize and
like they're actually all doing the same
thing all the way through so on top
they're clearly similar because
performance is similar but like we don't
know what's happening in between so so
then we try this analysis and then and
then it looks like different things are
happening in between but there's kind of
more coming yep CCA assumes that the
inputs are like linear you take a linear
combination I was wondering if you try
like deep CCA where you take a nonlinear
or why did you assume make the linearity
assumption yeah I mean that's a good
question you could definitely try deep
sea CA for CCA like I mean we have to
have some kind of I guess place where we
want to say something is like you know
like where we kind of conclude that
things are not that's similar to each
other representational e and we thought
linear is like kind of a good proxy
because you know layers kind of operate
linearly and so like you know things are
sorted within linear transforms of each
other it seems like a reasonable kind of
call to say okay that's sort of somewhat
similar
whereas yeah when you come to like not
like I think the nonlinear comparison
could also be interesting but yeah you
need to know exactly when to call things
similar and not somewhere oh man so many
questions okay I'll take one more
question and then maybe move on did you
have a question me yep okay Jack maybe
we'll chat more offline okay yep
similarity r/t layers
yeah so it's that's an interesting
question and what I'm about to get to so
so the altar is like I think for like
some models you see that but not for not
for not for others and so that is about
to come up yeah so so so okay so like
kind of so we saw performance is similar
and then a hypothesis says maybe they're
just all doing the same things that
doesn't seem to quite be the case and
now like kind of let's look further into
that and to look further into that let's
do something really simple so this are
the actual filters from the first
convolutional layer of of ResNet that's
kind of initialize with pre-trained
weights so you trick take your rest net
you pre train it on image net and this
is what the filters look like and sort
of you know true to kind of the
community's expectations you see all of
these really nice Gabor filters come up
so yeah so I don't think the weights OCC
I only operates on like activations like
I think it's like I think it's difficult
to sometimes make direct comparisons
between weights because your weights can
look really different but I think
functionally is like what we what's like
more interesting to us like I mean
there's like the standard experiment
where you have like a ground truth
neural network and then you train
something to mimic that but like even
they're like the weights are not going
to look like that's similar but like
kind of out with wise is yeah what we're
looking at well yeah so we're interested
like whether there are kind of
functional similarities in these they're
like like the actual outputs and so
that's what we we study by making your
your similarity measure parameterize by
the examples not by the weights it
factors out all these in variances and
permutations and stuff like that inside
of a network and like you mentioned
there are lots of papers legend sincere
that find all these relation
between the example mapping or the
ground matrix it something yeah like I
think almost all of these like even even
the paper those doing kernel based
measures yeah like kind of thinking
about it in terms of examples I think is
kind of really helpful for doing these
sort of similarity measures but okay
so so we're gonna do something even
simpler let's just look at like let's
just look at the filters okay so these
are the filters from conv one that we've
initialized from having pre-trained
freshly off of imagenet look at all
these gorgeous Gabor filters what
happens when we when we train this
network so we train it on this medical
data and well after training it actually
looks kind of similar so so maybe that
just means that you know these like
these kind of Gabor filters are perfect
for this medical data okay now let's see
what happens when we do the same thing
from random initialization so this is
what our our network looks like when we
randomly initialize it and again we're
gonna train it on this medical data so
we do that and oh man this actually also
looks somewhat similar so so so what is
going on because so over here like maybe
you could say oh there's interesting
feature reuse happening but but you're
also seeing the same stuff for random
initialization okay so that's like our
that's that's ResNet now we've trained a
whole bunch of other architectures and
some of them are much smaller so what
happens here well here's one of our very
small architectures it's maybe one-tenth
the size of the resonant so here it is
initialize with it's nice imagenet
weights and what happens after training
well it actually changes dramatically
and then again if we look at it at
random initialization and then look at
it off your training again it changes
significantly your connections a few
dozen skip connections activation I mean
we should interpret them by adding you
know having you across layers or
something like the real representation
is
and it depend on all the layers not so
this is just yeah so so because the
architectures are different we looked at
Khan Wan specifically for that because
it's sort of below all of that now you
are getting feedback from kind of the
skip connections that you aren't getting
but I think this this is also true for
for say like something like Inception as
well I'm just sort of showing showing
resonate here and I think I think what's
really going on is to do with sort of to
do with the size of these models so yeah
so two quick points one point that's
kind of interesting is that everyone
loves Gabor filters but these models are
not actually the smaller model which is
changing a lot does it actually really
seem to be learning at least the
classical Gabor filters and so here are
like places where there's a good more
filter and it's actually erased the
Gabor filter so like here's another
place where it's kind of good more
filter erase cover or filter erase and
then the other point is relates to what
my tousle already brought up which is
that like what we observe through kind
of further experiments is that the size
I think the size of these architectures
is actually kind of really impacting
what you see during this fine tuning
process so like the kind of picture we
have in our head it's sort of maybe so
random initialization and pre-trained
weights take us to sort of very
different parts of the space but sort of
somehow when your model is kind of large
and these imagenet architectures are
indeed in some sense seem to be large
for these medical tusks maybe you just
don't sort of move as much and then and
then whereas when you have sort of
smaller models you sort of change a lot
more now we've you know we've throughout
this workshop we've seen lots and lots
of interesting work on the neural
tangent kernel and sort of thinking
about these infinite with limits in the
kernel regime versus the sort of the not
the deep regime but like at least it to
my kind of high level understanding it's
not a direct mapping to what we're
seeing here so I think it's kind of
interesting to to sort of study this
further and try and understand try and
make this connection because there's
probably some kind of a connection and
sort of understanding why this is
happening would be really interesting
okay so um final point is that in the
paper we have a lot more kind of work on
sort of broadly thinking about
similarity and reuse there are other
interesting things we see like we can
store for our larger models our
similarity at initialization can be
pretty predictive sort of similarity
post training we can also
like kind of look at how much feature
reused is happening and this interesting
co-adaptation problem which happy to
chat about more offline but you know i
think time is running out and I don't
want to I want to make sure we get to
lunch on time so I wanted to end with I
think one of the most interesting
observations we saw during this entire
set of experiments
so one thing we observe again and again
across different architectures and and
across our different setups is that when
you train with pre-trained whites versus
training from random initialization
there is a huge difference in
convergence speed so this yellow line
here is what you get when you convert in
sort of your training your training
curve with with pre trained weights and
this blue line is what you see with
random initialization if you sort of
extend these far enough out they
basically converge to the same value but
there's this sort of huge difference in
in how quickly they converge and you
know when you when you first see this
plot you might think oh well this means
that transfer learning is doing its job
like you know you've learned some useful
features and you're sort of reusing it
and that's why you're converging foster
but we've also seen a lot of
counterintuitive results on the things
that larger models are sort of maybe a
bit lazier and just don't move as much
and it's it's still kind of not fully
clear exactly how much feature use is
happening in this in this process and so
we tried an experiment to try and
understand why we see this difference in
convergence speeds and the experiment is
very simple so we decided to initialize
by drawing weights IID from from sort of
the same distribution as random
initialization but rescaled to match the
pre trained weights so sort of here's
here's what this concretely would look
like if you initialize those pre trained
weights you'd look something like this
if you initialize with random
initialization you of course destroyed
all the features and it looks something
like this and then this thing which we
call the mean var in it I mean it looks
exactly like random initialization
except that it's scaling is different
because you sort of rescaled so how does
this do if we initialize what this and
train instead turns out that it actually
helps a lot with convergence speed and
we sort of students across different
architectures and across our different
tasks and so what's really interesting
here
you didn't very and grains from the
imagenet transfer the pre train weights
exactly and and it was per later so not
across the entire architecture that
wouldn't make sense but sort of perlier
take this and then initialize and so
what's really interesting is that yeah
this is this is a feature independent
property because we're sampling i idea
we've kind of destroyed all of the
features and we're only kind of keeping
the scaling but these are these are just
both for the the two large-scale medical
imaging tells me like that and when we
already know from and the relative order
of magnitude of the amount of data on
sorts first target times because uh a
dramatic impact here like did you look
at like Burt did you do all the stuff we
were doing the exact same things in 2014
but instead of training on the billion
or a dataset we were training on like
penn treebank or something like this and
that difference like the discrepancy
like and I've seen I know at least
internally at Amazon I have some
colleagues we're doing some stuff that
was like how many so many unsupervised
examples what I like look the fire fiber
choosing it by the cost of like how much
would I pay to get a million
unsupervised examples versus a hundred
extra labeled ones or something like
that and these numbered skin you know
could be it could be a very big
difference so I wonder with 1 million
versus two hundred thousand is are sort
of on the same order of magnitude and
that's why you see yeah so actually this
specific experiment we also so like I'm
not covering this here but we tried a
bunch of things where we varied the data
and so it's interesting but this is
actually pretty robust to varying the
data so you see the same sort of like
convergence like you actually see a
speed-up even when your data is much
smaller one thing you do see is that
with these really large image that
architectures if you have something as
small as like five thousand data points
that's when you see like a little bit
more of a gap between transfer learning
versus random initialization maybe it's
like two percent but then by the time
you've gotten to fifty thousand examples
that gap is like almost gone and and
like there's really no reason why you'd
a priori you want to use
like kind of imagenet sized architecture
on like 5000 examples like I think
that's sort of like also like kind of
yeah merits sort of further study we've
been talking about over parametrizations
I think that's like an interesting
related question but yep the main point
here is that this is like this is just
purely a feature like a property of
scaling and it's kind of a purely
feature independent property and so I
think there are a whole bunch of open
questions here especially related to
this kind of scaling part so
specifically is there sort of maybe some
scaling rule that explains this
convergence speed up we looked at this a
little bit but sort of not extensively
and there are differences but I think it
seems like it should be possible to
maybe pin this down and then I think we
also did some very preliminary
experiments on natural images and I
think we're seeing sort of similar
effects and there are kind of
interesting questions we can all skier
like you know if we train and then sort
of reinitialize but just preserve the
scale like you know do you see a
difference in convergence speed that's
like one of the basic questions we could
try and try and answer and then I think
there are sort of other questions that
also came up through this process sort
of like kind of maybe really kind of
getting at sort of similarity of
representations at initialization versus
after training and sort of how I do
things vary between large and small
models because at least I mean looking
at the weight certainly they're learning
very different filters so sort of
understanding that better would be
really interesting and then I think
there's also kind of scope here to
actually formalize things a little more
so I'm sort of seeing medical imaging
partially also as this way of seeing a
place where transfer learning does
provide some benefits some convergence
benefits but in a scheme where like the
the source and target distribution are
extremely different from each other and
so just understanding better what might
be happening there and maybe saying
something formal there could also be
very interesting and with that thanks
for thanks for coming
[Applause]
oh yeah absolutely I mean like honestly
if you look at how much how long you
train rent from random initialization
versus training on imagenet plus
training on the medical data like
training from random initialization is
going to be way faster like this but
this question makes scent like sort of
the reason this question is very
important is because people are just
downloading their models from github and
then sort of just doing the fine-tuning
so at that point you're like oh well you
know this thing is readily available so
do I want to do this or do I want to do
do something else yeah yep now we didn't
do 200,000 so I can chat with you
offline about that but you don't need to
do 200,000 - to kind of get a good
similarity measure you can do something
smaller than that the trade-off there is
between sort of like the number of data
points you're using and serve the actual
number of like kind of vectors you're
trying to find similarities over
this is why people so so okay so I think
there are two parts to this firstly like
people I think there's some outs of
people like using transfer learning
simply because they've seen other people
do it and kind of you train it and then
you can do this process and it sort of
works and you're like oh great
but I think I think in sort of settings
where people are doing extensive
experimentation like I know we think
Google like part of the reason transfer
learning is popular is I mean they have
resources but you're still trying to run
a lot of experiments and part of the
reason transfer learning is popular it's
because of this speed up you see in
convergence I think like you have to be
a little careful about this because um
part of the reason I think you also see
this fee up and convergence is because
you're also committed to this imagenet
architecture so like in the paper we
sort of studied this further but you
know I think like we're meaningful
feature reuse is happening if it is
happening is really in the lower layers
and so one way to get sort of similar
speed ups but maybe have a better
architecture is like you kind of just
reuse some of the weights and then you
sort of reinitialize stuff and sort of
train that away and this ties into like
kind of all kinds of other interesting
questions so like there's been this
interesting point in in deep learning
about this co-adaptation problem which
is suppose I have an initialization but
I only keep part of it and then I kind
of reset everything else how will those
work together and and it's kind of
interesting because for some settings
that's been a problem for this it
doesn't appear to be a problem so that's
also another interesting question to
study I think yeah yep
yeah absolutely so I mean I guess I
guess Zack and I were we like I guess
this is a discussion we mentioned
briefly earlier so if you have a very
very small amount of data you will see a
bit of a difference so I think we had to
get to five thousand data points on the
image net architectures at least and so
there we saw maybe like a two percent
difference instead of like a fraction of
a percent difference but then by the
time we got up to like fifty thousand
data points that kind of that difference
was really gone and then when we tried
on a much smaller architecture so bear
in mind before we were training this
enormous image and net architecture so
we tried on a much smaller architecture
and then there it didn't really seem
like there was much of a difference
so I think I think yes you do see a
difference but part of this is like a
because you've committed to an
architectural choice
[Applause]